and then a California Republican comes
on and and he starts talking and you're
not going to believe what happened when
he started telling uh a little bit of
his side of the story I want to get this
out there this is important that we know
what the science and the information is
in it saying even a recent follow-up
study in 2021 found that of 139
participants only 17 persisted in their
gender identity this was looking at
young boys 122 87% went back to their
biological sex you can't have
a state your point of
order I'm limit on
speeches yes there
is you assembly member
Gallagher you were given that
opportunity thank you sir all right yeah
they cut his mic he's literally reading
a study about boys converting and then
deconverting detransitioning whatever
you want call it and they cut his mic so
that is what's going on in the Banana
Republic of California under the
leadership of Gavin Nome and the next
Gavin Nome and everything
else